what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while while
she's trying to get rich for us just
trying to get our lunch money right
we're here we're back in the kitchen i'm
here also with the beautiful intelligent
polina marinova pompliano
bang bang what's up my instant pot isn't
in the background but
i will make sure next time that it is
great to know all right don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block fight go earn 8.6
apy in their interest bearing account no
brainer
if you compare it to earning three to
five basis points in your traditional
bank account
then you will see that 860 basis points
is much better
there's risk go do your research i'm an
investor
i sit on the board i'm a user today is
block fight day because today is the day
that they send out the interest payments
for
this month bang bang bang bang
go to blockfight.com pomp
blockfight.com pomp
let's do it what do you got for us all
right airlines are getting desperate
guys they need you to fly but you're not
going anywhere
like us we're in the kitchen that's why
the top three u.s
airlines are dumping their change fees
so in other words
if you want to change a flight there's
no fee associated with it anymore
uh first of all the change fee's always
been really dumb i don't know why they
have that
other than to make money uh but it's a
really bad customer experience
uh that's first of all second of all is
they are basically giving up revenue in
order to try to get you to fly more
so this is like they had done some
research here
that shows the change fees really do
prevent people from flying i guess
i don't know i thought that during covid
they suspended the change fees but now
it looks like it's more permanent
so united which oh my experience with
united has not been great
united started this trend and then delta
and american followed suit
american airlines what's up fellas all
right what else
zoom zoom zoom in they're
zooming zoom share soar after revenue
more than
quadruples from last year you wrote
about this today what do we think
yeah i mean look they're up 355 percent
annualized revenue quarter over quarter
or year over year
so last quarter uh what they were doing
in revenue
now they're up 355 from that my favorite
stat
is that they did 5.5 million dollars of
income in the quarter a year ago
uh but in this last quarter they did 186
million dollars in income
right so in in the reason is because
people are using zoom for work
for educational purposes for you know
friends and family
and now everybody knows about it i mean
even my grandfather in bulgaria knows
about zoom
well they also had i think it was like a
hundred yeah 148 million
uh active users last month uh which is
like
4 000 more than they had a year ago once
you get over
50 and 100 i cannot picture 4
700 what does that even mean well it's 4
700.
i know but it's not like double
quadruple anyway okay we'll get you a
calculator no problem
i mean look everyone's using it and
there's a paid product
that drives revenue people are paying
for that product which means that
revenue is going up
also means that income's going up and
therefore investors are speculating on
the stock that it's going to continue to
perform well
we'll see what happens but i think it
makes a lot of sense even i paid for the
paid product
one month and then i got stood up by an
astronaut
don't ask okay info infobip
is europe's latest unicorn company
meaning it's valued at over a billion
dollars
its next step is an ipo info bip is the
biggest business you have never heard of
some five billion people or two
two-thirds of the world's population has
used services you know what it does
no whenever you get an airline texting
you or uber texting you they're the
service
that powers that text message really yep
they do it more than like a twilio i
guess twilio's like a competitor
um it talks about that twilio is a
bigger business with revenues of more
than one billion last year compared to
infobip which has 711 million
um but twilio is loss making
whereas infobip has been profitable
almost since the start
but did you guys see that did you see
how i knew the competitor
and i knew that it was bigger but i'm
partial to infobit because it comes from
southern europe comes from croatia
and it is profitable being profitable is
a good idea right now
i think so all right so so what's the
point they're going to go public now
yeah
all right i mean that makes sense are
they going to go public in
that five billion people use this kind
of well i don't know if they use it they
received it yeah of course
so that's a misleading it became you
became europe's us unicorn last month
when it raised 200 million from one
equity partners okay and uh do they say
whether they're going to go public in
the u.s or somewhere else
um uh
uh uh uh uh uh no it doesn't say it
doesn't
oh whether the ipo will be in the u.s or
in europe
the ceo says he is still unsure it's
almost like i could write the articles
myself i know exactly the things to pay
attention to
but he would consider london or
amsterdam okay all right that's fine
i just think it's a cool little company
all right okay you can stop doing that
facebook users in australia if you're an
australian you're using facebook
you may soon be blocked from sharing
news
why the social media giant is
threatening to make it impossible for
you
users in australia to share local and
international news content
on both facebook and instagram if the
government passes new regulations
altering the financial agreement between
publishers and online platforms
wait so i'll get in like trouble if i
post news in australia
huh i'll get in trouble if i post news
on my news feed if i'm in
so weird you think it's really gonna
happen
maybe i feel like this is one of those
like oh my god the world's ending and
then the world doesn't end
i don't know australia had left facebook
with two choices removing news entirely
or accepting a system that lets
publishers charge us for as much content
as they wanted a price with no clear
limits
unfortunately no business can operate
that way yeah
that's stupid again the government just
stepping in and messing things up so
it'd be funny if like you try to post a
news link on facebook
and it's like uh uh uh yo government
will let you post
click here to write a letter all right
spotify's exclusive agreement with joe
rogan begins
today today today so what does this mean
why are we excited
i don't actually think that it's that
big of a deal it's just like
the the reason why
people are talking about is cause there
was a big number attached to it so 100
million dollars nobody knows
exactly how long that contract is for so
it could be for a year could be for
multiple years
uh and then also uh he's got the the
biggest podcast
who do you think his first biggest guest
or his first guest on spotify will be
i don't know and also don't you think
that if
his first day on spotify doesn't pop
like people expect it to
youtube will be like that sitting there
drinking it's coffee like huh
no why because he's still going to be
posting on youtube he's still going to
be posting highlights on youtube
oh what good what are you doing why are
you covering your screen all right
this story has so many twists i don't
even know where to begin
okay brad pitt who i believe is 58 years
old
okay is dating and has a new girlfriend
she has a german model her name is
nicole
potularsky she is 27
he is 58 okay she sounds mature so she
so they've been dating right
and then you find out she's married
to a 68 year old who has been married
five times before that
and it's okay though because they're in
an open relationship
so she's using her open relationship to
be in a relationship with brad pitt
what isn't this amazing and then
what do you guys see how excited she
gets about this nonsense no
no okay so she has been she's 27 she's
been married to this german restaurant
to our roland mary
who's 68 years old for eight years and
the couple have a seven-year-old son
how many twists are there in this story
um so anyway she's dating brad pitt now
as part of her open marriage
and then this is my you have to talk
into the computer this is my favorite
part about this page six story ready
oh shoot no it's not in page six it's in
another one oh no
oh no hold on guys hold on hold on i
read it somewhere are you are you
sending
my friend these stories to your friends
yes
okay so ready so um vulture which is a
part of new york mag
said that they called her husband right
they called her husband
and he said no comment and hung up
and they said in his defense we'd assume
nobody would be too
chatty if their wife started dating brad
pitt
you had to go back to the uh to the
article
to remember that he said no comment yeah
it was just funny
you obviously don't read the internet
and memorize things like me
sorry you got a joke what's your
reaction today to that
to that story stupid really why
what do you care about what other people
are doing no i just think it's do you
think they're happy
yeah there's actually one article if
there's one article titled that brad
pitt is happy so we're happy for him
same yeah sure whatever all right hey
um all right ready
okay i wish oh no no i don't like that
one come on hold on
unprepared today unprepared we're going
to start a show we're just going to
watch playing a scroll on the internet
uh oh i'm in truffle that was i'm in
trouble
no i don't like that one she's still
scrolling
um okay my friend likes to why does my
friend like to convert all of his
dollars into quarters
because he's got too much change he's
changed a lot
well i couldn't find a good one because
you kept running but you were unprepared
pressuring me
oh i sweated
you knew a lot about the brad pitt
dating some old dude's
wife got a kid who somehow someways got
no comment
would you have a comment that's it for
lunch money today while while she's
trying to get rich restless she's trying
to get her lunch money right bang bang
i'm out pray for me i'm in a weird mood
today
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6 percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends